actor Robert De Niro is in the middle of
a lawsuit against a former assistant
because the assistant embezzled money
from him and get this this was all in
the news
binge-watched fifty five episodes of
friends in four days while on the job
fifty five episodes of friends in four
days while at work De Niro and his
people very upset suing this person and
it's all in the news so I thought to
myself man fifty five episodes four days
that's a lot of friends episodes but
there's one person I bet could beat that
record someone who loves to watch TV at
work of course I'm talking about my
trusty assistant Sona I'm sassy I'm yeah
I'm told she's at her desk right now so
let's say hello right now live to my
assistant Sonam obsession hey Sona
hi and Sona
what did you think when you heard about
Robert DeNiro's assistant watching fifty
five episodes of friends in just four
days while on the job I was really
impressed by it but I also took it as
like a challenge I think I can I really
think I can beat her you think you could
beat this record yeah
no joking around because I want us to be
very honest here do you not watch a lot
of television while sitting at your desk
when you're supposed to be helping me do
you watch a lot of TV on the job I mean
yes but we work in television excuse me
we work in television say anything what
do you mean excuse me I didn't say
anything
excuse me are we work in television yeah
and it's important to know what's going
on in TV right so I watch TV to be
useful to the show so you're welcome
yeah
how many real hero yeah you are a true
hero to people but listen
Sona how many times have you been
watching a show that was like cancelled
in the late 90s or early 2000s how is
that research for anything it's good cuz
the actor still might be acting in
something and can I say though earlier
today you were watching a show from like
the 50's
so the 90s is at least closer to now
than what you watched that wasn't a show
I was watching movies of my childhood
what are you talking about
but that wasn't a show yeah that was a
that was footage of my brothers beating
me I liked it
okay Sona you want to take this as a
challenge we want to take that seriously
so you have between now and Thursday to
watch 56 episodes of friends while at
work to break Robert De Niro's
assistants record do you think you can
do it
yes I've already started I'm already 12
that does it but wait a minute
is it not true that you started even
before we pitched you this bit I was I
was already watching it and then you
said that I would do this so I put up
going I've had it on the entire day okay
all right so what we're gonna do is have
you why are you looking at it now while
I'm are you watching it right now
it's wait what's the episode it's the
one where Monica writes out all seven
erogenous zones and then she starts
going through them I think that
everybody knows which scene I'm talking
about but it's really good oh the scene
I'd still don't know the erogenous zones
but all right Oh God
no all right we're gonna check back in
with Sona tomorrow to find out how it's
going we'll check in with her and Sona
all right
so I'm obsessing everybody